at this point right now we've just
finished the filling process and that
drug product is coming over to us in
order to be packed out into a shipping
configuration so that we can ship it to
the downstream mode after merch two
experimental vaccines failed in testing
the drug maker decided to play a
different role in the pandemic helping
rival Johnson and Johnson scale up its
vaccine manufacturing efforts
that really created a nice opportunity
for us to start a collaboration with
Johnson and Johnson and be able to
leverage their covet vaccine product and
be able to add capacity by leveraging
our line and our team Kim desura is the
plant manager at Merck's vaccine
manufacturing facility in West Point
Pennsylvania her plant produces at least
500 000 doses of the Johnson Johnson
covid vaccine every day and this month J
released the first Merck made shots for
distribution from Europe to other
countries we're right now on the
manufacturing part of the campus and it
has its own ZIP code it does it does
have its own ZIP code Public Health
experts consider the J J vaccine key to
protecting underserved communities
around the world
the J J vaccine only requires one dose
and can be refrigerated unlike the
Pfizer and moderna vaccines which need
to be stored at lower temperatures
so how did Merck's West Point plant
prepare for this immense operation
we got an exclusive behind the scenes
look at what it takes to manufacture the
J J vaccine
so what's actually happening here at
this plant the relationship between
Johnson and Johnson and Merrick have
really two two parts so we'll be
manufacturing the drug substance part of
the vaccine which is kind of the active
ingredient of our vaccine products we'll
be doing that in our Durham North
Carolina facility here at the West Point
site we're responsible for the drug
product zura says that after this
facility receives the Frozen drug
substance from Johnson and Johnson the
first step is to store it here in this
freezer room Trevor Brightwell is the
associate director of vaccine operations
at the West Point facility
Brightwell says these freezers are all
new brought in specifically to store
covid vaccines and each freezer holds
5.5 million doses of the drug substance
your typical freezer in your house might
be running at -10 degrees C these are
running at minus 70. okay so with these
type of products the colder that you can
keep it maintains the quality of the
drug substance when the drug substance
is ready to be put into vials it is
moved to the filling facility
here the drug is thawed and then sent to
the filling line where exact volumes of
the drug are dispensed into glass vials
and individually capped and once they
pass the automated inspection they are
transferred to the pack out room
so we're in the very final step of the
process right before the product is
about to go out the door because
vaccines are a temperature sensitive
product it's important to minimize their
time out of refrigeration
so Merck developed this 3D printed tool
to help workers pack vials as quickly
and efficiently as possible
this tool grabs 39 vials in one go so
workers don't have to load the vials one
at a time after the vials are ready to
go they are shipped back to Johnson
Johnson to handle the final packaging
and distribution
preparing for this operation involved
getting new equipment and modifying its
filling line to accommodate the J J
vials all of which Merck says it
accomplished in less than a year
how long does it normally get ready to
manufacture vaccines and do this process
typically if we're bringing in a new
product to a filling line it might take
you know a year or two to be able to
really go through all the qualification
and and the transfer details part of the
reason Merck says it was able to adapt
in just a few months was it's almost 60
years of vaccine manufacturing
experience
we have a long history and a lot of
different types of vaccine products
including you know products that are
pretty similar to the Johnson and
Johnson products so it really helped us
to be able to adapt our current
procedures quickly another reason is
that Merck received help from the U.S
government in March the Department of
Health and Human Services said it would
spend 105 million dollars to help Merck
upgrade its facilities
a typical part for a filling line may
take months to receive and we were able
to turn that around in sometimes days
and weeks jazura says Merck plans to
continue partnering with jnj until the
pandemic ends or its manufacturing
capabilities are no longer needed I
think all of us have been touched by the
pandemic and so the ability to really
contribute a potential solution for that
is is just really remarkable
foreign
[Music]